سببها ذوبان الانهار الجليديه وينذر
التغير المناخي سكان الارض بكارثه وشيكا
وهي انتشار اطنان من البكتيريا الضاره وهو
معدل مقلق لكوكبنا ذوبان الانهار الجلديه
في العالم بات ظاهره تشكل خطرا محدقا على
سكان كوكب الارض والسبب ارتفاع درجات
الحراره والتي ستؤدي ايضا الى ارتفاع
مستويات سطح البحر في السنوات المقبله قال
قم باتزداد مع مرور الوقت وسيناريو ذوبان
الكليبتا واردا حيث دقه العديد من العلماء
ناقص الخطر في هذا الخصوص ودعوا الى
التحرك بسرعه لتدارك الوضع مع تواصل ذوبان
الانهار الجليديه في اوروبا وامريكا
الشماليه والتي قد تؤدي ايضا الى حدوث
انهيارات ارضيه وثلجيه وفيضانات قد تغرق
العالم الى جانب اطلاق اطنان من البكتيريا
الضاره فمن ظهور بدايه العصر الصناعي زادت
معدلات درجات الحراره حيث قدر فريق علمي
ان تواصل ذوبان ان تواصل لذوبان الانهار
الجليديه يمكن ان يؤدي الى اطلاق اكثر من
مئه الف طن من الميكروبات في البيئه على
مدار 80 عام القادمه وبالتالي فان زياده
تدفق الميكروبات الى الانهار والبحيرات
والمضائق والبحار سيكون له تاثير كبير على
جوده المياه النظيفه والصحيه وصحه الانسان
وفق مراقبين في ارتفاع درجات حراره كوكب
الارض ستؤدي الى احداث خلل كبير في النظام
البيئي والقضاء على الانهار الجليديه التي
تعتبر طبعا مخزن طبيعي للمياه المجمده
[موسيقى]